meal don't make me come in there I feel
like I hear a black hole being built
[Music]
we don't know how to manipulate a black
hole because a black hole is a voracious
eater so let's say you had a black hole
on your desk and it fell to the floor
right it would start eating Earth and it
would continue to do this until the
entire Earth was inside the black hole
and you know how big an earth Mass black
hole is no about the size of a plum
it's very difficult to really conceive
when you think about it yeah because
you're limited to your five biological
senses exactly and the universe is
repeat with me under no obligation to
make sense to you and guess what it does
a very good job of that